everybody has to find his own way I work
on the characters you see that's the
most important thing I work on my
characters I make files on the computer
for different characters every day I you
I I write fiction only in the early
morning for some reasons I cannot write
during the day I must wake up every day
at six am I right from 630-1030 everyday
a.m. and then i put a very tiny details
you see it's like I will I try all the
time to see the character if I am
writing about a lady i must see her very
clearly so i put for example how her
hair how her hair is I mean the color of
the hair if she does smoke which doesn't
smoke the way she's dressed it many many
tiny details until at one moment I see
the characters the characters are no
more imaginary you see I believe they do
exist and this is a moment when I began
the writing I began the writing with a
very general idea about what's going to
happen in the moment which is most
mostly is going to change during the
writing but I keep writing with my
friends my characters who are now my
friends because they do exist with me
until another moment which is a another
moment happens then in the other moment
is the great moment of fiction writing
in my opinion when I don't have or any
more control on the characters the
characters become independent it sounds
very mysterious but this is exactly
what's happening I mean every morning I
not I
on the screen of my imagination I see
what they are doing and I describe what
I see and it's it's an unbelievable
pleasure for a writer to do this you see
and this will explain many things for
example are I don't have control on the
endings on my novel I did not choose the
index many of the opinions of my
characters I disagree with you see but
now they are totally independent there
is I mean they have their own life and
they decide for themselves and I just
follow them you see to describe the
right